hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
preventing a war is difficult hot
tempers can get in the way of cool and
rational reasoning
and the result of war is something that
nobody wants to live through
to stop a war takes discussion and
diplomacy
reason and thought but what if a war
could be stopped by just one man
a man who chose to trust his gut instead
of a machine
and not just any war but a nuclear war
between the united states
and russia in other words this one man
single-handedly stopped what would have
been world war
iii it sounds like something out of a
science fiction movie
but one day back in 1983 this exact
event happened
stanislav ifgrafovic petrov a russian
lieutenant
literally saved the world without him
it's possible that you wouldn't be here
and the world as we knew it could have
ended on that day
so what happened on that fateful day and
what would have happened if the two
superpowers nuked each other
well get comfortable and get ready for
an insane story
this episode truly was one of my
favorites to make
it's the 26th of september 1983 and 44
year old russian military lieutenant
stanislav petrov sits at his console
it's been a regular day so far but
suddenly his screen
lights up it's five american
nuclear missiles coming straight towards
russia
he had a choice to make should he pick
up the phone and advise a retaliation
strike against the united states
he doesn't have much time to make a
decision if he acts
america would be nuked and a world war
would erupt
if he does nothing he risks losing his
fellow countrymen's lives
in a u.s nuclear attack at this point
the weight of the world is on his
shoulders
but we need to rewind here how did the
world get to the point
of one person standing between normality
and complete annihilation
shortly after the end of the second
world war in 1945
hostility started brewing between the
united states and the soviet union
and from 1947 onwards the world got
divided into two geopolitical blocs of
power
the eastern bloc led by the soviet union
and the western bloc
led by the united states what ensued for
the next couple of decades
is what we call the cold war though this
period
never had an actual war between the two
countries it was characterized by a
highly intense conflict for global
domination
which involved espionage and military
conflict in foreign countries through
proxy wars
the korean wars and vietnam wars were
two such conflicts
the two global rivals competed with each
other to become the leader in various
aspects of science
technology and warfare through space
exploration
nuclear development and an arms race
while the united states had an edge in
building nuclear weapons after the
ending of world war ii
the soviets soon caught up by the 1960s
the two were so much on par with each
other in regards to their nuclear
capabilities that they were capable of
destroying each other in a nuclear war
this led to the concept of mutual
assured destruction
which implied that each one's offensive
weaponry surpassed the defensive
capability of the other
to drive this home in 1961 russia
tested the tsar bomber it was a hydrogen
bomb
that was the most powerful weapon ever
created
it was the equivalent of 54 megatons of
tnt
or to put it another way all the
explosive power of
all the bombs used in world war ii at
the same time
times 10. when the russian zarbomba was
dropped
the flash of the blast could be seen 1
000 kilometers away
or 630 miles and the mushroom cloud was
64 kilometers high or 40 miles high
villages 55 kilometers away were
flattened
and damage was sustained by buildings
hundreds of miles away
radio communication was disrupted for
over an hour because of the radiation
the pilots who had dropped the bomb
almost lost control of their tu-95
bomber from the shockwave blast
and this was despite being 50 kilometers
or 30 miles away
and placing a parachute on the bomb so
it could slowly float down to earth
while they had a chance to escape
third degree burns were possible from
hundreds of kilometers away
and shock waves from the blast was still
being recorded on its
third revolution around the earth it's
insane to think
that in the original soviet designs the
tsar bomba was supposed to be
twice as powerful needless to say
the possibility of nuclear war was
always a dark dread
a dread that loomed overhead the
citizens of planet earth
throughout the 60s 70s and 80s
it was september of 1983. tension were
running high between the east and the
west
the united states was busy developing
psychological warfare exercises against
moscow
and the soviet union was expecting that
the us was going to launch an attack
and there was a reason for this the
soviets had just shot down
a korean airlines commercial flight that
crossed into soviet airspace
killing a congressman from georgia among
269 passengers
anxiety had started to mount when the
flight from new york to seoul with a
stop in anchorage
wasn't heard from for several hours then
came the unavoidable savage troop it had
disappeared from the sky itself
by heat-seeking missile fired by a
soviet su-15 interceptor
among those presumed dead united states
senator larry mcdonald and at least 30
possibly 40 other americans
and an australian family of four in
washington secretary of state schultz
said this was no accident president
reagan at his californian ranch
was said to have been briefed
continually birds can scarcely
express our revulsion at this horrifying
act of violence
that flight 7 was substantially off
course and well into soviet airspace
over some of the most sensitive and
jealously guarded airspace the soviets
have
because underneath is a nuclear
submarine base
an air fighter base and a missile
testing range
from moscow the silence was deafening
on the early morning of the 26th of
september 1983
three weeks after the downed korean
flight the world came the closest
it's ever been to ending
lieutenant stanislav petrov sat down at
his computer and began his shift
at cerpikov 15 a command center
stationed just outside of moscow
he had been on his shift for a few hours
when suddenly the ballistic missile
early warning system began to sound
[Music]
this alarm indicated that the soviet's
early warning satellites over the united
states
had detected an intercontinental
ballistic missile being fired from a u.s
base
shocked petrov began to try and wrap his
head around the situation of what had
just happened
suddenly the system set off four more
alarms
one after the other implying that the
united states had launched a total of
five
intercontinental ballistic missiles the
warning system had changed its alert
from launch
to missile strike and it showed that the
reliability of these warnings was at the
highest level
petrov was now truly shocked
petrov was a critical link in the chain
of decision making on retaliation in the
case of a missile strike by the us
he had studied radio engineering at a
soviet air force base in kiev and joined
the soviet air defense forces
and rose through the ranks over the
years his role now
was to oversee the staff that monitored
signals from the early warning
satellites
there were no specific rules for
deciding if a warning was a false alarm
or not
it was totally dependent on petrov and
whether he decided to report to a
seniors
the circumstances demanded that any
early warning of a missile strike be
reported promptly so that those at the
highest level of command could make a
decision
quickly as juniors at the station
waited for petrov to make a decision he
sat frozen in his chair
and couldn't bring himself to quickly
dial and report
once reported to his superiors it would
all be out of his hands and probably
result in a nuclear strike against the
united states
but doing nothing would risk his entire
nation
take a second and think to yourself what
would you do
holding a phone in one hand and an
intercom in the other petrov pondered
over the consequences that his decision
would lead to
after five minutes he decided that the
warnings from the system were false
alarms and reported the same to his
superiors at the headquarters
they trusted his decision and didn't
order a missile strike on the us
but now petrov had to wait had he made
the right decision
did his failure to act caused the death
of millions
lieutenant petrov stressed in a sea of
his own thoughts
this went on for roughly 25 minutes
he then realized that if there was an
actual attack he would have come to know
within that time
the more time that passed the more
relaxed he became
finally he concluded he had indeed made
the right decision
so how could this have happened the
false alarm was set off by primitive 80s
technology
the soviet satellites that were
monitoring the incoming missiles
mistakenly identified the sun's
reflection off the top of clouds for a
missile launch
the coding in the program was supposed
to filter out such wrong stimuli
the coders didn't do a good enough job
the code was later rewritten to avoid
such dangerous incidents in the future
in interviews given during his later
years lieutenant petrov revealed that
the early warning system of the soviets
had been introduced in haste as the
united states had launched a similar
system
and because of this he didn't consider
the system 100 reliable
and believed that humans being the
creator of such computer systems
were wiser than them the critical
decision was taken
based purely on a guess quote i had a
funny feeling in my gut
he told the washington post he explains
that it originated from his skepticism
of the early warning system and the
realization that if the us was indeed
going to attack it wouldn't just fire
five missiles
so what would have happened if the us
did retaliate
if petrov had chosen to interpret the
warnings as a real attack in 1983 the
soviets may have launched a fierce
attack on the united states
leading to a retaliation from the us
ending in mutual annihilation for both
nations
a 1979 study by the us office of
technology assessment states the
following
a nuclear war between the u.s and soviet
union would cause around 35 to 77
percent of the population of the united
states to have been wiped out
and the soviets would have lost 20 to 40
percent of its population
any war between the two nations would
have inevitably led to their allies
getting involved
leading to a third world war
so what would a nuclear bomb do to a
city
a 10 kiloton bomb detonated on the
ground of times square in new york
would explode with a flash so bright
that it would briefly blind people for
hundreds of miles
a massive fireball with core
temperatures running at millions of
degrees
would immediately erupt everyone
and everything within 100 feet of the
blast would be completely annihilated
a one mile radius would be charred and a
500 mile an hour pressure wave would
expand out
destroying everything in its path and
all of this
would happen within a few seconds of the
blast
radioactive particle dust would be
spread and scattered all over the city
people exposed this dust would suffer
from acute radiation syndrome
showing early symptoms such as dizziness
nausea
headaches and vomiting within a matter
of hours
this would be followed by symptoms such
as fever seizures
diarrhea hair loss and bleeding in the
mouth and under the skin
victims may also experience more severe
symptoms over the next couple of weeks
and most of these people would
eventually die an electromagnetic pulse
generated along with the blast would
disable electronic devices such as
computers
cell phones and communication towers up
to several miles away
if more attacks are carried out the
sheer amount of smoke would block
sunlight
and plunge the global temperature by
several degrees for years
leading to a phenomenon called nuclear
winter this may affect crops
and lead to a famine so i think we can
all agree
we have to say thanks to petrov for
helping us all avoid
such an outcome
after the nuclear missile incident was
avoided at first
petrov was initially praised for his
calm while facing an unprecedented and
critical situation
but soon after this he was investigated
over the incident
among the questions he was asked during
his interrogation was
why had he failed to record everything
in his logbook
to this he famously replied that he had
a phone in one hand and an intercom in
the other
and didn't have a third hand he was let
go with a reprimand
according to petrov it was just a matter
of pride because he had found multiple
bugs in the early warning systems
and because of this it would become
unfavorable for his employers to reward
him
it may also be why his story isn't
widely known
petrov was long forgotten after the
incident and was reduced to growing
potatoes for a living
in fact almost nobody on earth knew
about their almost destruction
until 1998 when a retired commander of
soviet missile defense
yuri v votinstev had his memoir
published
in the memoir he told this story and
that was the first time that this became
public
and from this point the world finally
recognized what petrov had done and
lauded him for his role in averting the
third world war
in 2006 he received an award from the
association of world citizens in the
united states
in 2013 he was honoured with the dress
and peace prize
and in 2014 a danish documentary called
the man who saved the world was made
about him
petrov died at the age of 77 on may 19
in a moscow suburb where he lived alone
on a small pension
it is a very humble end to a man who was
so pivotal to world history
again without him we might not be here
and i just find this story fascinating
the story of how one person
changed the course of history and
potentially saved millions upon millions
of lives
by essentially deciding to do nothing
but let's take this opportunity to
collectively remind ourselves that
nations going to war in this fashion
is something that nobody wants
thanks so much for watching and i hope
you enjoyed the episode
i may already be at 3 million
subscribers by the time this goes out
so a huge thank you to all of you who
decided that you liked my videos enough
to subscribe
i'm thinking of doing a live chat over
at the cold fusion discord to celebrate
i'm sure i'll have more details on that
later
i also wanted to do a quick correction
on the last video i said that a
neighborhood was bought by an investment
firm
but i didn't make the distinction that
that neighborhood wasn't open for buying
to the public
and was intended only for wholesale it
was pointed out by some of you so i
thought i'd clear that up
anyway my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion
and i'll catch you again soon for the
next episode cheers guys
have a good one cold fusion
it's me thinking
[Music]
you